we haven't stopped drinking I'm still
weeping it's right and things are about
to just get crazy mark ruffalo I'm Chris
Hemsworth hello my name is Jeff Goldblum
and I'm here to be with you for a moment
well try not to wreck this ask us your
questions and we'll do our best
well I'll tell you I it was great
filming this movie I I love to had a
very good time my father so much best we
because we never really spoke on screen
I mean beating each other up in one of
the Avengers films and so we had an
opportunity that kind of explored this
whole relationship and which started
under the Avengers press if you rewind
the tape somewhere you'll see the two of
us discovering each other and messing
around having fun discovering that we
won in Civil War and yeah it's a starter
on team yes the revenge juice everybody
you know mr. Anthony Hopkins and Cate
Blanchett and Chris Hemsworth or himself
and Loki played by Tom Hiddleston and
Mark Ruffalo who is the Hulk and Bruce
Banner they're all funny but what I what
a cast she's I met Sir Anthony Hopkins
once and a little party III think he's
wonderful
we were looking all married couple
Hawkins oh yes they were make a breakup
sale but they actually like each other
they get back together and they break up
again until same some love and get back
together then fear that the other one
doesn't love joy and joy
one of my kids is impressed the other
dog the other $2 the care so one out of
three is awesome
all my kids started impressed my 16 year
old like not so impressed anymore my 12
year old like the girl at school and she
didn't like her back so she's like does
that make you feel bad she's like no dad
I'm I'm really cute I'm a really really
good girlfriend and my dad's a holic to
training
she's an arrow to gym of in a raw
chicken yeah that's that's Mark's advice
yeah and my mind I'll try that one
they're just lifting whites they know
what's about to Collier - its functional
trying a gentleman respect making
yourself uncomfortable for the people
that have less than you you know putting
yourself out there in ways that you
normally
and yeah respect respect and equality
[Music]